okay i successfully unmuted
yeah wonderful
so thank you everyone uh
and i guess i want to make the same
pitch
that water made in the beginning that of
course seeing some people faces
does improve my eventually improves my
life so
uh if you're willing to keep your video
on that would be lovely
so i'm going to tell you about actually
something where
the connection to the title of this
semester or workshop is more in the open
question than in
actually what we can answer uh it should
be an application of
reinforcement learning but instead what
we're going to do
is applying classical kind of learning
and maybe
the question is can we do something
better if the players might
use fancier format of learning so i want
to talk about
learning as it might be used by players
in the game and this joint worked with
jason gaitonda who's
my student at cornell so
oops something's not so good
yeah um so i guess repeated game
you think of something like packet
wrapping
every iteration there are new packets
anyone who send them and maybe
uh the games that i have previously
worked on though that's not the game
we're going to consider now
uh it's congestion that's causing the
problem
uh and things slow down as their
congestion
and as you might know there is at this
point uh
growing and i think beautiful literature
that learning is a good way to think of
what players might be doing in a game or
at least
is a interesting solution concept with
uh reasonable theorem so i guess
the assumptions are that agents play a
fixed game over and over again which
could be routing or actions
they selfishly try to maximize their own
on utility or cost
and minimize the cost and that they're
using some sort of learning and the
classical the most known notion that's
getting used here is that they use
some form of no regret learning and then
the idea is that initially they don't
know what to do but later on they do
and you all know what the no regret
condition is they do at least as well as
a single condition this hindsight
i like this behavior assumption uh
despite that the open question i'm going
to end with
is that maybe reinforcement learning is
offering us
that should offer us better assumptions
here um
i guess i want the properties i want is
um
oh sorry that there are
many many algorithms of this fort so
there are easy algorithms that can be
implemented it sounds like a decent
behavior assumption or i'm asking the
agencies hey
there is a really good solution please
notice it or at least do at least as
well
if something much better that was also
easy to see then well how come you
didn't see it
and then i guess compared to
other notions it's less restrictive and
there
there's some evidence that it might be
true in practice in some settings
there are nice theorems uh i guess
classically
maybe at this point 20 years ago we had
all the serums about the price of energy
in games and almost all of them
all but very few exceptions they extend
to the same theorems about quality of
outcomes assuming
the weaker assumption that people do
every player
employs a form of no regret learning so
this was a
super fast one-minute history of where
i'm coming from
and now comes the main point i want to
make all this work
makes an assumption that unfortunately i
would use
certainly not reasonable or possibly as
bad as silly
and here is the assumption that really
bothers me
is that we are assuming uh that
every iteration the players play a whole
a new completely new copy of the game no
carryover effect no effect between runs
beyond the fact that they learned
something on how to play from the
previous round
so if you're asking oh again i have
problems with this
uh is this a reasonable assumption and
just to get you
started on how good the assumption is or
how bad the assumption is
uh if you're talking about morning
russia
then i think this is reasonable no
matter how bad
monday traffic was by tuesday morning
the cars are gone
uh but it's not reasonable on the second
by second
um uh
interim or millisecond by millisecond
internet traffic
if a packet's not getting through then
either is still sitting there trying to
get through or it got dropped and we
going to resend it
in any event any unsuccessful packet is
bothering you
in the next iteration continues to
bother you in the next iteration
uh and this is where i'm thinking that
in
and that's sort of to foreshadow what i
won't be able to do and what is maybe
the open problem here
is that in the version of cut off
of car rating or morning russia traffic
uh
no regret learning seems like the right
assumption
and maybe in the minute second by second
package traffic
it's not uh your your action
has a direct effect on the future namely
if you didn't get your package through
it's going to be in your hand
and you're going to have to send it
through later and this is true for the
other guys also
so that's what i'm trying to study uh
what can we say
in a in a competitive game where players
are used some form of learning
and i'm going to study it not in the
very realistic assumption
of packet tracking on the internet but
in a super simplified model
of packet tracking not in the internet
so let me tell you what is the model
that we're studying i'm happy to ask
actually
anyone feel free to ask questions in the
middle especially
clarifying questions so here is the
model that
we are looking at it's an infinite
re-running system
it's queues uh in
that are getting packets and they want
to get send them to a server and it's
going to be that these queues
each are learning using their own
machine learning to figure out which
server is any good
and where are the other guys going
sending date packets so
you know i want to go someplace where
the service is pretty good
and there's not so much competition so
every queue will have some sort of
arrival rates a burn only process
at rate lambda for arrival rate and
every server has a service rate
probably the mu j that the services
arrives every iteration each queue gets
to send
one of its packets to one of the servers
their choice and they're going to try to
learn which one
if the serv the server will choose one
of these packets to serve
and if it doesn't succeed serving the
packet either because it failed or
because there was too many packets sent
that way
then it's going to send it back so
literally this is what i wanted to mow
the leftover effect if your packet
doesn't get served
then i guess it's going to have to get
served later it's sent back to you and
you can try it again in the sex
situation
and again as i said every cube will use
a nordic learning algorithm to figure
out what to do
so this is the mall um but i'm going to
ask
is the very reasonable algorithmic
question
how much bigger server capacity do i
have to guarantee
to make sure that this system will will
be stable and not
that we are not going to have an
infinite backup of cues
so i'm going to compare how much
capacity do i need if they're selfish
compared to how much capacity do i need
when they were not selfish they just
you know coordinated on on who should
send that
um to get everyone on the same page
again two maybe things that are should
take one second each
two super simple examples example one is
vancouver server so that's what it looks
like and i
assume i don't have to spend even a
second on this obviously what you need
is that the arrival rate should be
strictly less than the service rate
and then the queues will stay stay
banded you can think of this
either as a very simple q sense server
question
or uh as a biased random walk with
by a bias towards the zero line zero
point
and i guess we also know that if mu
equals lambda then they actually back up
and you bigger than on the that lambda
bigger than mu then it backs up linearly
obviously
uh the second super simple case and it's
still
almost as super simple is
uh one queue and is many servers so this
is important to remind you that i made
the assumption that
you can only send one packet at a time
so this queue really needs to figure out
which server is the good one and then
try to send uh
there so this is really a multi-arm
bandit problem
uh these these servers are the items and
the queue
there's no competition just wants to
figure out which one is the best server
and try to send it there
and i guess what that we need is that
the lambda should be less than the
biggest
new and in fact this model was
studied in a nibs 16 paper by krishna
nissan johari
where they actually did a much more
thorough analysis
of how the cue how the packet lengths
pack it back up they'll actually go up
for a while while the
q is trying to figure out what's going
on and then go back down so a very
detailed analysis of what happens to q
lengths
um what we're going to do is a
competitive version
so there are multiple queues multiple
servers
they're going to be non-cooperative and
selfish
and i guess i'm going to want to measure
again remember the question was
how much ser how much capacity do i need
on the servers
to have this non-cooperative service
thing work out for them
before i can do that or i can even tell
you what might be
the right answers or questions here i
should give you the baseline
so what's the baseline the baseline
would be
you know suppose i coordinate how much
capacity do i need if i were to
coordinate
so maybe you won't be surprised the
answer it's very
natural if i uh sort the queues and the
servers
in the natural order that is better
better servers
first and uh higher reliable rate of
queues first
then this is the condition uh for every
k
the top case server should have bigger
strictly bigger capacity than
top k cubes is super not surprising
remember again everyone can send to one
server at a time so the top kqs can only
use the top case servers if they
even if you tell them how to coordinate
on it and if there's not enough capacity
on those they're in trouble
and indeed this is the condition
so hopefully this sounds believable
to everyone so now comes the real
question
okay i don't i don't coordinate i want
to have them compete
how much server capacity do i need then
and i admit i swept a detail under the
rug which i have to fish out from under
the rug before i can
talk to you guys is if there are
multiple packets arriving to a single
server
which packet will the server choose
and i guess i want to propose that there
are two natural answers to this question
one is uniformly random one of them and
the other one that the packets come
timestamps and i do all this first
so i either give priority by age or i
don't do that and then it seems like
uniform random is
maybe the most reasonable
so here is the results that i'm going to
want to give you a little hint of
or a little ideas of how we prove of so
step number one uniformly random is
really bad that is this
um nqs i might need as much as a factor
of n
times more server capacity to get
anywhere
if the selection is uniformly random
then unless you
have insanely more server capacity
selfishness
really really kills you and this one i
will basically convince you with an
example
in about a minute and then on the
uh more constructive or positive side if
you do all this first
all you need is a factor of two
that is if you have twice as much server
capacity as what
would have been needed had they
coordinated then
as long as they all are reasonable
learners which by which i mean they
satisfy the no regret condition
then they're going to not back up
again the factor of 2 is sharp here that
is less than a factor of 2
not do it so let me give you a sense of
what
what kind of proofs of how does this
work so
first of all the uniform selection
example i think is a little insightful
in thinking about how this works out
so here is my uniform selection example
um i can make this c um something
polynomial and
n but actually to keep it simple think
of c as a large constant
like a hundred or your choice of a very
large constant
this system has a they see slack
in the capacity that is if i were to
coordinate or i have to tell them that
look guys every one of your queues has
its matching server
it has a service rate factor of c above
what your arrival rate is please use it
and then we're all set everything is
coordinated
but maybe it's also tempting to believe
that you will know that
well actually that's not what's going to
happen
and what's wrong here and what might
happen instead
is that many of the queues will say that
you know
my assigned queue server is really bad
it basically has a you know running end
kind of service rate
if i only go higher up like i would get
you know it's random selection if seven
of us go up we get a one in seven
service rate isn't that a lot better
uh and a whole bunch of them uh some
polynomial depending on n we'll choose
to go up and that will be the nash
equilibrium here
uh we'll learn it will do it in learning
there is no
if you satisfy the noregret condition
they will all switch up
or many of them will switch up um and
what's wrong with switching up
is that the big q cannot cannot clear
like the
the service rate for this top queue here
uh
actually i'm pointing probably to the
wrong side uh
the top queue i'm not doing well is the
pointers
top queue here has too high service rate
and it won't be able to get across
um so i guess
i'm claiming that this doesn't happen if
you have timestamps
and in fact a factor of two is enough
uh here instead of giving you any hint
of the
example that shows that the factor of
two is tight which
interestingly is actually pretty similar
to the previous example
uh i'm going to want to give you or use
my minutes here
to give you a sense of how the proof
goes
so here is a rough idea of the proof
it's a potential function proof what i
would like to say
is actually let's start from this is an
infinite system
if i run a claim that it will stay
stable
i have to realize that in the infinite
time horizon
all kinds of horrible things will happen
so what i have to basically prove
that when the system is in a bad state
it will
actually keep getting better it recover
so i need a measure of what's a bad
state and then i need
an argument that when that state is bad
life tends to get better and that's
basically what's happening that is done
by a potential function
the intuitive definition of the
potential function is what i wrote here
that is uh phi tau is the number of
packets that
are h tower order and the potential
function is sum of all the five tasks
so every packet that has a particular h
tau
contributes tau to this potential
function so this is really the sum of
all the edges of the packets that's what
this potential function is
but i prefer to think about it that way
because i want to argue about the five
tasks that is the number of tower or the
packets
separately uh the main tool we're going
to use
is a nice uh probability theorem of
pimentel and rosenthal
which says that in random process if
it's sufficiently regular
and has negative drift whenever phi is
large
then it remains bounded in expectations
so what we going to prove
that the expected expected value of phi
that is the sum of the edges of all the
packets will stay banded
uh because as i try to prove to you in a
sec
it's sufficiently regular and has a
negative
i didn't even define sufficiently
regular so definitely
uh uh next slide will focus on the
negative drift and then i admit to you
what
sufficiently regular is which is a more
technical part
um so what i want to say is that if you
satisfy the no regret assumption
and you have a factor of two slack in
the capacities
then uh will imply negative drifts
whenever this phi is big
that's sort of the main theorem i want
to prove
and instead of going through these sort
of details of the proof
i want to give you an idea of why the
proof is true i hope it is a level that
most of you will
see you'll say that yeah i guess that's
believable
or sounds reasonable so i want to figure
focus on a particular age say tao and
want to look at
all the toweled packets or all the cues
that have towel packets
and want to know for a long enough
window
and one will say okay uh what are these
guys doing
and i want to say there are two cases
case number one
as indicated by this picture or suggest
to indicate by the picture
that distilled queues during this window
spend a lot of packets towards the best
best servers remember they had priority
so whenever they sent something one of
them got served
because tower order they all have
priority
so probably a lot of them got served and
therefore
they the this taofi that is the
packets that have tower order decreased
the number because they got served
i have to worry about the second case
which would say
actually this servers didn't send it to
these
good servers they somehow apparently did
something else because
maybe the learning algorithm messed up
or i don't know why
um and then i guess i want to claim no
regret will kick here
i want to say oh you guys are not
sending none of you are sending to the
good servers
but you have priority have you sent to
the servers you would have had priority
why didn't you send it to the servers
so that must mean if you satisfy the no
regret condition
that you're getting at least as much
service as you would have gotten at
these servers
and that's all i needed it's either
you got served but case one or
if you didn't use this to get served you
must have been getting served someplace
else because of the nordic condition
and what i need to do is of course do
these all scales simultaneously
and add it up for every every towel and
imply the negative fit
to be honest i did sweep a technical
detail
under the under the rug or a couple of
technical details
um one i almost admitted and then i
slept it under the rug
uh to make this work i actually instead
of wanting no regret in
expectation i probably won it in high
probability certainly that's how we can
make it work
and instead of running it over all the
whole tri zone
i definitely want it over every large
enough window
as i pointed out this is an infinite
system
bad situations will arise many different
bad situations will arise
so different queues will have backed up
and i want them to
have the regret condition whenever it
got really bad
the next window you satisfy the no
regret condition
so again the main message is because
it's an infinite system
super unlikely bad things will happen
and i want you to
have a condition that helps you recover
whenever that happened
and indeed if you have an autograph with
high probability over sufficiently long
every sufficiently long window that's a
good enough
condition for this uh the second thing
is that i was actually cheating
with the potential function and instead
i'm using
a deferred decision version of the
potential function
[Music]
tau i t here is or t i t here
is the age of the ice q
the oldest packet in the ice cube at
time t
and this expression that's on the screen
instead of phyto is an estimate of how
many tower packets will there be at that
point
given the age of the order stuck it and
that's our actual potential function
not the number of packets the reason i'm
doing this
is because sufficiently regular in
actually proper mathematics was that it
had to have bonded moments
and this estimate on the number of
packets has banded moments whereas my
original one does not actually
so it's a technical distinction
but i think the main idea was the use of
the
no regret condition so let me actually
end this
a bit of discussion on on what i
promised in the beginning of what might
be
closest connection to the reinforcement
learning or other form of
more long-term learning so i like
learning in games i still like it i have
worked on it now for a while
but i think these carryover effects are
an important feature that our community
has been
mainly or completely ignoring it and i
think it's nice to get back to it
and i think it's a natural nouright is
not the matching condition here
in this carryover effect because of the
direct effect
of your actions have
[Music]
i could imagine working on other
problems where carryover effects
actually apply and many of you might
know that this sort of
killer application here is at auctions
where the carryover effect is called
your money
if you win if you win in an action you
have less money if you
lost you have more money which is maybe
a bigger
killer than this queuing uh
but maybe i want to end with this uh in
an upcoming work
uh we actually have a result
saying something that even more strongly
says that no regret is the wrong form of
learning
what does no regret do no regret
evaluates whether you like to send to a
server
by the instantaneous success you have at
the server
wrong measure but you should be
evaluating
if i were to send to the server for a
long time
how successful will i be on the long
term time
that is not the same measure as the
instantaneous success
and in fact if uh the learners or the
queues are patient enough to look at the
long term success rate
as they as the thing they're optimizing
then it turns out this e over e minus 1
which is only 1.58 something
is enough for extra capacity so more
patient behavior that
actually needs less extra capacity
you can ask me why didn't i give this
talk instead and i admit there are two
reasons
in the process of writing it up and
hopefully i will get posted very shortly
but second because i don't actually have
a learning result here
this is a nash equilibrium result in
part because i don't know what the
definition of learning i want to use
so that's where the open problem comes
in the matching version of learning here
should be something that you don't
evaluate what you like
step by step you evaluate it over
periods as you
somehow figure out how you change your
strategies and
i think many of you in the audience if
not every single one besides me
is better experts in all the possible
notion of learning
i hope you can give me good advice of
what definition of learning
might match this sort of longer term
patients by the cues
and thank you so much
thanks a lot eva um
do we have any direct question uh to
eva and then we're gonna open the floor
to just more general questions to the
three
speakers i have a question
uh just a technical question i may have
missed this in the beginning of the talk
uh what what's the um
uh model of arrival of packets to the
queues
when you say they receive packets at a
certain rate so what does
that mean they're newly
independent rate lambda i for qi
hmm
so so there's no
adversarial aspect to this no
and i guess it's that's a good question
um
you you may be thinking that this
use of pimento rosentha serum uh at
least to me came from the adversarial
queuing theory
paper uh and we did wonder whether the
same results we're doing here would work
in an adversarial
mode i suspect it would but i guess
the paper that we have doesn't works out
the random one doesn't work out the
adversarial version
thanks
so eva when when you had one cue you
made the connection to the
multi-arm bandit and then you moved to
multiple queues which naturally would
connect to
multiplayer military bandits but you
didn't make that connection
is there a reason
so possibly it's my ignorance of what's
normal multiplayer
multiple bandits uh i guess i know
more of that form of where the players
are coordinating
right yeah and i'm not aware of uh
like my players are competing uh
yeah so i don't so we have diane on the
call perche who gave a talk this morning
about a related topic and simina bransai
also will talk about similar topics so i
don't know if you guys want to
say something if you see a connection or
if you want to keep the discussion to
later